[Musique]
combien de types de tourbières
existe-t-il il y en a deux et c'est la
source d'alimentation en eau qui les
distingue les tourbières ombreux trophe
dépendent des précipitations comme la
pluie le brouillard ou la fonte des
neiges pour leur apport en eau ce sont
des milieux acides ou la teneur en
nutriments et minéraux est faible la
végétation est surtout dominée par des
mousses appelé ce bug en agriculture on
exploite ses tourbières pour la
production de canneberges ou pour
extraire la tourbe
le deuxième type ce sont les tourbières
ministre off
elles sont alimentées par le
ruissellement des autres surfaces ou par
la nappe phréatique
en plus des précipitations comme cette
eau a souvent traversé des roches ces
tourbières sont riches en minéraux et la
biodiversité y est habituellement plus
importante
les fameuses terres noires de la
montérégie idéal pour la culture
maraîchère sont en fait des tourbières
minéraux trophe drainé et aménager lancé
deux types de tourbières on peut
retrouver des arbres c'est pourquoi les
tourbières sont aussi exploitées en
foresterie
mais peu importe le type ce sont des
écosystèmes fragiles est précieux car
ils mettent des milliers d'années à se
former
[Musique]